a little bit of background about me
my name is Emma I was an engineering
manager and data platform at stripe for
a couple years starting in 2017
back when data platform was just a few
people and the whole company was a few
hundred people but even then we were
very data heavy so I think a lot of the
learnings we had back then is still
probably helpful for a lot of you all
so let's get started
so why exceptional correctness like why
does that even matter right and the
reasons because as you can imagine
stripe deals with financial data we deal
with transactions we deal with actual
money it's very important that we do
things correctly it's not like a social
media platform whereas clicks or
Impressions it can be a little fungible
it's all right but for us it needs to be
absolutely correct some of the systems
that run on data at Stripes even as
early as 2017 were for example treasury
you can read the description what that
means it's a little like fintech stuff
thrown in reconciliation billing and a
lot more so literally if our daily
platforms didn't work we wouldn't know
how much money we had in our banks
so what did data platform look like back
then this is obviously very simplified
but
um we were around three people when I
joined because uh half the team moved to
a different team because on-call was so
bad
um and but we maintained everything that
you see here
um so all the different pieces here are
essentially still the backing bone of
what stripe data platform looks like
and um it was really great
um that we owned all of it for data
correctness because we can insert it at
different points in the system
so how do we be correct at stripe
so we start with as you can imagine a
lot of checks that are automated we
provide these checks for our users our
users can also write their own checks
and they're basically a very simple
airflow decorator which is the scheduler
that we use that you can call in and
what happens is these jobs will run
automatically after the job if you use
the correct whatever decorator that you
you want and these decorators are simple
like the ones you can see here it's like
we want to make sure that the data is
increasing it's never decreasing or
there's any keys
and there's actually more complicated
checks where it actually checks the
primary keys in the resulting table
actually exists in another table so that
there's no weirdness going on
um so anybody can write these checks but
we'll make it really easy to call them
in
um and another thing if uh you know like
kind of part and parcel with this is
what do you do when when something goes
wrong and we have very complex fallback
behaviors defined for all of our data
jobs so for example you know if it's not
super critical we get everything fresh
it actually does automatically fall back
to using yesterday's output so it
doesn't do a rerun it just Falls it
tries three times or however many times
you the user defines and it will just be
like I give up it's okay I'm going to
continue the pipeline with yesterday's
output and then a little bit higher than
that is like okay well maybe something's
wonky with today's data let's use
yesterday's data or rerun the pipeline
and continue with that and you know as
you can imagine like the most severe
case would be like you actually block
the pipeline and just like not move
forward and just like just halt
everything
and that actually is also marked with a
with a with a decorator that says this
is really severe and we don't want to
move forward if it's the case and
there's there's even more than this and
we provide all these as well
um one another way that we make sure
that everything is correct is we do a
lot with S3
um eventual consistency it's not an
issue anymore since 2020 but if you
worked at a company that started before
2020 you will probably see code that
guards against this um but still ghosts
in the closet uh we basically wrote Our
Own metadata layer to make sure that
things are consistent we basically write
extra metadata alongside that street
data to make sure that all pieces are in
place before we let the pipeline move on
and we got so into this metadata layer
that you'll see eventually that we
actually moved on to a whole new table
format as an extension of this it gave
us a lot of capabilities in terms of
efficiency in terms of like knowing what
data to lift up
and another thing that our teams built
is typesafe libraries for spark so uh as
you can imagine like we use a lot of
data frames in spark we don't have Pi
Spark
you know even now but but we did use a
lot of Scala and
um our Engineers really wanted to be
sure that we are super correct as much
as possible and Spark didn't provide the
right encoders for us all the types that
we support at stripe were very special
snowflakes sometimes because we use
we have weird Ruby types and we
need to support it in our spark job so
we actually went down this ESC Rabbit
Hole in order to make everything super
type safe so we actually implemented our
own encoders to make sure that every
single type at stripe is supported in
spark so people can use typesafe
operations
um in addition we actually eventually
create our own UI based observability
platform just for data it was quite
primitive when we started building it
but the idea is eventually hydrated to a
point where it could be the point where
you would specify decorators for
fallback Behavior or specify behaviors
for kind of tests but what it does right
now is actually it has a tight
connection with airflow and also the
metadata layer so it would know when
jobs start running what kind of data
like the size of the data that it
inherited what the column names are what
the column types are you can compare
day-to-day runs you can compare
um kind of like the the run time and it
can do some uh inference on when the end
of the pipeline is going to be given how
things are running right now one of the
traits of you know our data pipeline is
that stripe is like the dag is extremely
deep so sometimes it's really hard to
predict when your data is going to
alternate land and your lot of
stakeholders come and ask or do the
science teams and ultimately us like if
something failed or something's running
slow one is ultimately going to arrive
and this UI helps answer that problem
without everybody you know paying us all
the time so hopefully you know that gets
a little bit better but essentially this
is
um kind of like some of the essential
data that we use and again it pulls data
from airflow and just the metadata layer
on S3
um and then it's time to bring out the
big guns so we care about accuracy so
much that we actually recompute the
universe quite frequently
um part of the reason is like some of
our data models are not totally
immutable even though it looks like they
should be
um and to make sure that we are
completely accurate when these when when
a lot of like these kind of changes
happen
um to these types of data that you know
should be immutable is we actually
recompute that Universe for our most
important jobs this means we take all
the data from the beginning of stripe
and recompute it
um
the good thing is we are not like a
Facebook or you know like these big
social media media companies that have
so much data they're doing that is like
completely impossible or prohibitively
expensive for us it's actually still a
doable thing and we do rely on it
sometimes
so just just so you know like it's okay
to bring out the big guns you don't have
to you know like completely like
engineer yourself out of this sometimes
um and then I'm going to talk a little
bit about trade-offs as you can imagine
all the things we mentioned so far as uh
latency right as one of them all the
checks that we do all the fallback
Behavior do the retries as well as
recomputing the universe that takes time
so that means we're sacrificing how long
our pipelines run and
um sometimes even like
predictability in terms of like how
standard deviations tend to be quite
large sometimes when jobs do fail
because we add checks so many different
layers of the stack
so that's one of the things we did
explicitly make
um a destination to
sacrifice on
another thing you can imagine part and
parcel at latency as well as reruns is
like cost we actually spend a lot of
money
on compute as do most companies like our
AWS spend is probably one of the largest
spends and that's also something that we
decided to just deal with because we
really do care about correctness so much
and
you know the Silver Lining to all of
this is that because we were forced to
kind of be so correct we actually need
to also start looking into tools that
make sure that we can be a little bit
more efficient um given the situation
that we're in so we actually do
um like I mentioned like the metadalier
we actually moved on to Apache Iceberg
um around 2020 and that really helps us
make more efficient data lifts because
you know you have a lot more like you
know just Melody that on like which
columns that you need to lift and and
you know like which columns you need to
recompute even if it's a recompute the
world job it does the the storage layer
much more efficiently so that was really
great and um and you know having so much
metadata and having a table format like
Iceberg also lets us do cool things like
day locality which
um you know like you can store data in
other locations but your big job can
also like lift the correct data from
different you know regions
cool
and then uh the conclusion here is
build a good data system
um but but really you can add steps for
data correctness all throughout the
stack from beginning to end and because
we did this so early on at stripe we
just we sleep better at night right we
know things will be the correct uh as
much as we would prefer it to be and
because the system is designed the way
it is it's also very self-serving um you
can do correct constructs on your own
and you will know that things are going
to be okay
um yeah so then you can be happy and
sleep well at night
and that's it that's the talk thank you
so much
[Music]